hey this episode was sponsored by head
and shoulders
[Music]
125 million years ago
in what is now china dinosaurs walked
the earth
[Music]
and a few species of small feathered
dinosaurs climbed
trees this is cynornithosaurus
although they couldn't truly fly they
could glide
which helped them evade predators and
catch prey
what makes these dinosaurs unique is how
well preserved their fossils were
normally when you find the dinosaurs
it's a pile of bones and that's all
there is
in between the feathers and the parts of
the feather we saw little bits of skin
and you can tell that they are skin
they're not just random bits of rock or
broken up bone or something
because they have a particular kind of
cells within the structure which are
just like
the skin cells that we find in humans
today
well my first thought when i saw these
was this is dinosaur dandruff and i was
already
planning to write the paper uh with the
headline of we have discovered dinosaur
dandruff i thought great
so these dinosaurs may have had the
first known case of dandruff
but it certainly wasn't the last our
skin cells are constantly replenishing
themselves
in fact every second 500 new skin cells
are created
and as they move up through the outer
layer of your skin the epidermis
they flatten out and harden until they
fall off
one by one in fact over your lifetime
you will shed about a hundred pounds of
dead skin
but we don't really notice this because
skin falls off in such tiny microscopic
pieces
except for some people from some parts
of the body skin comes off
in larger flakes typically from the skin
under the hair the scalp
and this is what's known as dandruff now
around
half of everyone on earth suffers from
it
so there are actually a lot of
scientists who study this condition
and i'm flying to cincinnati to head and
shoulders headquarters to visit their
lab
okay do you need a break or something no
it's funny like okay because i'm not
really sure what i'm getting myself into
right no
no i am going to have my head
swapped what is that what is that all
about i mean this is something that you
do to people all the time oh yeah
every day you're gonna cotton swab my
scalp
yes and we're looking for
what so uh we
are gonna be looking for the um
anesthesia
that is on your scalp okay so what do i
need to do
so i need you to have a seat here
let's see and i just put my head in here
yeah put your head face forward okay
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
part your hair
so now i'm going to take my swab and i'm
basically going to grab
off your scalp so then what i do is i
take this
these are sticky plates here that i can
plate
the malestesia on and what i can do is i
can add a stain
throw this under the microscope and this
is the
individual cells of malassezia here
malassezia globosa is a fungus that
lives on your scalp
it thrives in the warm moist environment
under your hair
and it is thought to be one of the
causes of dandruff
so how did my swab come back well i have
malassezia
living on my head this is actually what
the fungus looks like this is the lawn
of the malassezia globosa fungi you say
a lawn
it's a lawn so basically you can see
those little dots they're all individual
colonies
and when they grow really close together
like that that's a lawn
kind of like a bunch of grass
now that i'm close to it and actually
smell it it smells like bread
yeah well you know it's a yeast you know
it's a free living
fungus just like the saccharomyces that
are used to make bread and make beer
with so could you make bread with this
uh no i wouldn't want to make bread with
the yeast off of
your scalp not right now have you been
tested
i've been tested yes and what did it
come up i have a decent amount
so but we all do so it's on everyone's
head
it's on everyone's head as long as you
have hair right
but if everyone has malassezia why do
only half of us get dandruff
well malassezia lives on the oils called
sebum
secreted by your skin the fungi release
enzymes called lipases that break down
fat molecules oh so this is one of the
lipases that malassezia produces so this
is something that malassezia uses
to get food but unfortunately as a
byproduct of that it also attacks your
scalp
because it produces free fatty acids
that irritate the scalp for some of us
those molecules are perceived as
invaders if you will
and all the defensive forces that we
have will get turned on
to repel essentially these invading
molecules and those defensive forces end
up causing
this collateral damage that we interpret
as an unhealthy scalp and dandruff
one of the scalp's defenses is to speed
up the turnover of skin cells
so instead of taking a month for skin
cells to mature and reach the surface
they take as little as seven days when
they get to the surface
the adhesive function from one cell to
the other hasn't been lost
and so they shed as these clumps of skin
cells three or four hundred together
which we see as a dander flake
[Music]
the dander flakes are just an indicator
of a fundamentally unhealthy scalp
underlying it by any measure you can
dream of making
dandruff skin samples show elevated
levels of inflammatory cytokines
histamines which cause itching and blood
proteins on the surface of the scalp
indicating that the skin is not acting
as a good barrier between your insides
and the outside world but it goes even
further than that
down to the level of gene expression
scientists
took swabs from healthy scalps and
dandruff scalps and then they
extracted the rna effectively markers of
which
genes are being expressed and how
strongly
and then they compared the two groups
and they found that
there were nearly 4 000 genes which were
systematically
either upregulated or down regulated in
the dandruff scalps
compared to the healthy scalps for
example immune and inflammatory response
genes were upregulated
things like lipid metabolism were down
regulated and it all kind of makes sense
but
now that you know that there's a
difference at the level of gene
expression
how do you actually treat dandruff so
this
is the the lawn of malassezia this is
the malassezia
with a spot of the head and shoulders
active put on it
the malasia just doesn't grow where that
head and shoulder is active
actually is these active ingredients can
be zinc purethione
selenium sulfide or peroxine they are
controlling the metabolism
of those malassezia cells that are
leading to irritating substances
so the idea is to suppress their
bioactivity to some extent
so that we're reducing the level of
irritating substances on our scalp
that trigger the irritation and hyper
proliferation
and bear disruption that we talked about
now that we understand like these
clusters and these gene signatures of
dandruff is
can we reverse these gene signatures if
we treat with head and shoulders so this
is the group of dandruff at baseline and
these genes are all down regulated
and then these genes are up regulated
you can see if you treat with just a
cosmetic shampoo that you really don't
make a difference
in those jeans but if you treat with
head and shoulders after three weeks
this signature looks just like somebody
who doesn't have dandruff
and so you're looking at 3 700 genes
kind of all clustered all on here and
you're seeing them
flip around they're going from an
unhealthy signature to a healthy
signature
so head and shoulders reduces the
malassezia irritants on the scalp
changing your scalp's response and
ultimately reducing skin flakes
so unlike dinosaurs we don't have to
live with dandruff
but in their case the presence of skin
flakes reveals something important about
their biology
they had evolved warm bloodedness and
hence feathers as a way to keep warm
but once they had feathers skin could no
longer be shed in one piece like a snake
but instead in tiny pieces so in fact
although it's an amusing discovery it
actually had quite an
important or profound point because it
tells us that dinosaurs while
commonly called reptiles are on the side
of the birds and the mammals in terms of
physiology
they were definitely blooded
hey i hope you learned something from
watching this video i certainly learned
a lot making it
and if you want to find out more about
head and shoulders research or about how
to get rid of dandruff i will put a link
to their website
down in the description so i want to say
a big thanks to head and shoulders for
supporting this episode of veritasium
and i want to thank you for watching or
watching